Whenever you study a new topic, it
feels good to solve questions based on that topic. You solve all the questions
for example. If you are solving 10 questions,
then
you solve nine questions out of 10 for sure.  You find that
this happens but when you have moved ahead from that chapter,
you have
also read second chapter and third chapter in the same subject. Now
when you test four chapters, then you attempt only
six or seven out of 10 questions from the same chapter.  You see,
now we have studied Physics and
Chemistry,
we are solving full length paper,
we are able to solve only four or five questions from the same chapter,
so where does the difference come, so the
thing is that when you follow all these approaches.  When you
walk together, a pressure
builds up and under that pressure,
you get the question wrong, then we have to
ensure that whatever question
comes to us, based on the content that comes to us,
we never  You will not make any mistake and trust me,
if you insure this thing then
your chances of selection in the exam
increase a lot.